i'm daniel dubrovkin known as db i am
head of engineering at artsy in new york
city
um we of course use github we use
private repositories on github we also
do a ton of open source and a lot of our
repositories are actually open and
public and our engineering team
contributes to them and other people
outside of the company contribute to
them as well
so we try to replicate the open source
development style as much as possible
with pull requests with code reviews and
things like that
but internally and in many ways we feel
like we're part of a much bigger team of
thousands of engineers out there and we
want to work the same way as they do
so
let's take our uh core api project it's
it's a ruby project it's built uh in uh
with the library called grape and uh it
talks to a mongodb back-end
and the api is is pretty straightforward
restful api that returns json data so in
order for me to contribute to something
like that i would fork a main a master
repository on github on the artsy the
name of the project all our project
names have physics names so this one
will be called gravity and so that's a
private repo of our core infrastructure
i'll fork that uh i will work on my fork
i will write all the tests i'll make the
feature complete and i will make a pull
request into the master
repository into the into the repository
from which i have forked and i will ask
one of my peers to code review my code
changes the change will be merged some
automated build will pick it up test it
and so on and so forth and then
one after it has been merged all the
tests ran this may be deployed to
production within an hour
we do all kinds of deployments during
the day for many of our projects it's
just the natural part of our iteration
yeah so my typical workflow every day is
to merge the changes from upstream
continue working on maybe the feature
bug fix or whatever i'm working on make
pull requests and and repeat
um so i have quite a bit of experience
with various source control systems uh i
have worked with
uh with cvs in the 90s i have worked
with a clone of befores called source
depot at microsoft very extensively very
robust very good system for when you
have 800 developers for example
i've worked with subversion and i have
been working with git for the last few
years and specifically with github
i think force works really well when you
have hundreds of developers and you need
some kind of transactional system where
everybody comes one after another and
where you can have literally thousands
of developers committing code almost at
the same time think of like windows
something very very large and very very
heavy
subversion works fine for small projects
but today git has really taken over
because it's it's a perfect uh revision
control system for distributed teams and
uh think of an open source project where
you can potentially have thousands of
contributors
you can't have a centralized repository
that holds you back so that's why we use
git we mirror and model our development
process on open source software
github has also made vast improvements
on top of git and has given us ui and
workflow with pull requests that are
very hard to replicate so i've always
been doing code reviews in the past but
what i would do is create a patch submit
the patch to the maintain of the
repository or maybe some
external code review system and then
the main person will merge my patch
by doing a lot of work with git we don't
have to do much of that
would get we can make pull requests and
just merge with a magical green merge
button
so
github is
has given us the magical green button
and that's why we use it